i am so excited tomorrow we will be
joined by
tom morello who of course was most
famous for rage against the machine
yes uh audio slave too right would you
say
and a true innovator tom does this thing
he uses something called a kill switch
i'm not a guitar player i don't know
what he kills me i could get no wiki you
know wiki's a guitar player he can tell
you hey steve
hey now
[Music]
so a kill switch is essentially it's
it's
a button or a knob he does it with a
knob i have a button installed
so it kills all of the feed coming out
of the guitar so it's like
you know this is the noise coming out of
the guitar
so the switch doesn't like that and one
really cool thing that he does
is he makes it sound like a record
scratch so he's taking his left hand and
going like
like that and then with the right hand
he's doing the kill switch like a dj
going
like
[Music]
that's it that's what he does can you do
the helicopter sound he does with his
guitar
it's like a little quicker with the
delay but it's kind of
i can't do that one that well but it's
you need to kind of [ __ ] with the
effects
he does this other thing you know like
like the 90s west coast hip-hop guys
have that it almost sounds like a
theremin
it's that like kind of a high-pitched
thing so he has a whammy
pedal and what he does with that is he's
he's bringing the pitch of the guitar up
to octaves so it kind of sounds like uh
like dr dre [ __ ] kind of like this
[Music]
yeah he gets crazy crazy sounds out of
his guitar
it's really quite remarkable
why are you not in a band why i like if
i could play like you
by studio somewhere where why are you
here
this is my studio
i'm considering starting a band with you
obviously i might be your lead singer
that you're looking for i can you know
show me a riff that you've invented
of your own i mean this is something i
was playing the other day it's not that
great
yeah see that's good all right i can
work yeah but i don't think you're the
singer for that howard
uh no no i got it i got i got a i got a
vocal already
deep thing like like singing like your
father like oh
that could work
[Music]
there you go